monsieur le ministre de l'Industrie ma
question sur la réindustrialisation de
notre pays j associe Guillaume casparian
député de chartre d'ù vous revenez de la
célébration la semaine dernière en
présence du président de la République
d'un investissement de plus de 2
milliards d'euros d'un groupe médical
international qui montre le succès de la
politique d'attractivité de
l'investissement trose France qui est
évidemment le produit de la mobilisation
des acteurs locaux cela va de soi mais
aussi la simplification administrative
la suppression de la CVAE et la
fourniture d'une énergie décarbonée bon
marché celle de notre énergie nucléaire
dont le régulateur a encore dit
récemment qu'elle pourrait être fournie
à des prix contenus par l'énergéticien
national mais vous lancez aussi la
Semaine de l'Industrie vous l'avez fait
hier qui valorisera l'enseignement
professionnel et en particulier les
lycées professionnels et le ministre des
Finances se trouvait il y a quelques
jours encore en Nouvelle-Calédonie pour
sécuriser la poursuite de la production
niquel de notre industrie automobile
européenne à tant besoin ma question
porte précisément sur la décarbonation
des 50 sites les plus émetteurs de CO2
vous avez signé en effet les 50
conventions qui détonnent les détails et
la quôtité pour chaque site de l'aide
qui leur sera apporté et en particulier
dans deux axe quel sera le rythme et
l'effort qui sera consenti en
particulier pour le passage à la
biomasse des sites charbonniers je pense
à saintavolde mais aussi à la
transformation du sel à dombal et
également le deuxème axe celui de
l'hydrogène car pour
décarboner la chimie et la cidrurgie
dans la veillée de la Moselle ou celle
de la SA il faudra des ressources
considérables à la fois pour produire
l'hydrogène vert et aussi le transporter
dans cette mesure nous attendons
monsieur le ministre un effort décisif
notamment pour la recherche y compris
pour les universités comme celle de
laorine notre industrie lourde est
devant une étape décisive face aux
doctrines de la décroissance c'est le
socle de notre prospérité merci merci
beaucoup mon cher chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Roland lescur
ministre en charge de
l'Industrie madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député La Cresse merci pour votre
question la semaine dernière vous l'avez
dit nous étions à chartre ville cher au
président de la commission d'affaires
économiques avec le président de la
République pour annoncer un
investissement exceptionnel un grand
groupe danois pharmaceutique un des plus
grands au monde choisit à nouveau la
France pour investir un montant
exceptionnel ces bonnes nouvelles
n'arrivent pas par hasard vous l'avez
dit elles sont aussi le résultat de 6
ans de travail acharné de ce
gouvernement et de ses prédécesseurs
pour rendre la France attractive la
réindustrialisation est doit se faire
partout chez vous en meurt et Mosel
territoire d'industrie s'il en est au
bout du monde en Nouvelle-Calédonie
aussi où le développement de la voiture
électrique donne de nouvelles
perspectives au nickel et c'est la
raison pour laquelle Bruno Lemaire y est
ce défi il fait face aujourd'hui à deux
écueils majeurs le premier nous aurons
besoin de ressources énergétiques la
biomasse l'hydrogène de l'électricité
décarboné vous l'avez dit et avec madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
nous aurons l'occasion de vous présenter
un plan notamment sur l'hydrogène qui
vous est cher et qui est cher à votre
territoire deuxème défi majeur celui des
talents nov nordis c'est 2000
travailleurs pour construire le chantier
et 500 emplois durables pour cette usine
qui en détient qui en occupe déjà 1600
et pour ça j'engage tous les
parlementaires de tous les bancs à
s'engager dans la Semaine de l'Industrie
qui cette semaine met en place 5500
événements partout en France qui vont
donner envie à nos jeunes hommes et à
nos jeunes femmes de rejoindre
l'industrie la réindustrialisation c'est
un combat qui doit nous rassembler qui
doit concerner tout le monde la
formation l'attractivité l'emploi la
lutte contre les discriminations tout ça
doit nous conduire à mener nos jeunes
vers l'industrie et à gagner ce combat
de toute une génération merci monsieur
le député merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre